we're joined now by CBS college football
analyst Rick Neuheisel and Rick I want
to tell you this there's some games on
the schedule right but I feel like the
game that no one's really talking about
enough because we have the showdown
between Texas owe you and obviously
Alabama's playing am LSU Florida but
Rick why isn't anyone talking about Iowa
versus Penn State this week maybe
because they saw I will play offense
last week in the big house it was a
tough it was a tough go for Brian
ferrets Kirk's son who is the offensive
coordinator there they managed all of
one yard rushing right they managed to
score three points and gave up eight
sacks and four turnovers ever than that
it was a brilliant day but I think it's
going to be a whale of a game and I
think this is a this is an opportunity
for Penn State to kind of I heard you
talking about all the teams that are
sitting there and that undefeated
portion of their year right are they
ready to prove themselves are they going
to follow up into oblivion Penn State
came into this year kind of under the
radar
you know McSorely was no longer there I
think this is a Penn State opportunity
to really show themselves as maybe the
number one competitor to Ohio State in
the big ten to do so they're going to
have to play a whale of a game Iowa
City's a tough place to play
Iowa's defense I mean they're often
struggled but Iowa's defense was up to
the task last week holding Michigan ten
points under 300 yards of offense so I
think it's a great game
Iowa usually wins this game and I just
heard a stat that James Franklin since
going to Penn State is Owen six on the
road against ranked opponents so they
got to prove something to get this done
Wow man that he's never beaten a ranked
opponent on the road since he's been
head coach the rest day yeah that's
crazy unbelievable but that's the
matchup honestly that I think people
aren't talking about but the people are
talking about some other key matchups
especially when we look at what we think
is probably not even enough points for
the scoreboard to handle which is
Oklahoma's
it's going against Texas this weekend
how do you see this one playing out Rick
well is it the odds makers are saying
it's going to be the scoreboard going
crazy I think they got the over/under
somewhere around 75 Wow which is by far
and away the most points for the weekend
listen Texas has struggled mightily
against the past they're given up 325
yards a game now they've been beaten up
with the injuries in the back end we saw
him play almost exclusively man coverage
against Joe burrow and the LSU team and
that didn't work they the Tigers score
45 that night so they're gonna have to
have some answers on the back end
because Oklahoma is averaging over 600
yards of offense every game so that to
me if they do that then they give up
Jalen Hertz on the ground Jalen Hertz
has nearly 500 yards rushing already
this year
I think he's 23rd in the country and
averages eight point eight per carry so
it's it's pick your poison for Todd over
Lando and that Texas defense but the
good news if you're a Texas fan is
they've got Sam Ehlinger who I think
puts on a cape every week and just mines
a way to to lead Texas to if they don't
win at least give up a heck of a fight
Ehlinger is is John Wayne of Texas
football I mean he is studied tough I
mean I think it's much seek television I
think Oklahoma ultimately wins the game
but I think you're going to be really
treated to some extra special
quarterback play Rick Neuheisel CBS
sports college football analyst joining
the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison here
filling in for rich but you know Rick
one of the things that and I want you to
put your head coaching hat on for a
minute okay if I'm trying to devise a
game plan if I can yeah dust it off for
me a little bit coach when you look at a
guy like Jalen Hertz and you've had a
chance to really watch him extensively
with with CBS over the last couple years
but you're seeing a different
quarterback this year a guy who's been
able to throw we knew about his running
ability but him as a passer this season
how would you try to stop him in in this
football game well he's
he's much improved and I would I would
go back even a year while Lincoln Riley
certainly deserves some credit so too
does Danny knows who was the
quarterbacks coach there at Alabama last
year while while Jalen watched two at
Unga by Lowell play I think he got
better in a matter of fact he was ready
when they needed him in that SEC
championship game he goes in there and
goes 5 for 5 on third down to help beat
Georgia and get Alabama back in the
playoff but he's clearly a much more
refined quarterback today than he was
when he was 20 62 as the starter at
Alabama where you know Lane tippin's
offense had him looking deep and then
coming down to a check down and then
running this to me has much more in
terms of scanning the field getting
across things and when he's able to do
that and you get guys like CD lamb
running deep open patterns it's been
wildly dangerous I mean he's had over
400 yard passing games he's run for as
much as a hundred and 75 with his own
legs it's a tough tough offense to
corral which we've known about Lincoln
Riley but in terms of a guy who can run
between the tackles
you know Kyler Murray was a guy who
could run outside but this guy can run
downhill that makes it really really
tough for a defense to figure out a way
to stop him well Rick where's almost
what six weeks into a college football
season yet Alabama finally will take on
a ranked opponent so as they take on
Texas A&M 3:30 p.m. Eastern Time on CBS
so Rick what will we find out about
Alabama after playing Texas A&M this
weekend well I think this is an
interesting contest now the oddsmakers
say it's 17 points in Alabama is going
to roll and and you know there's no
reason to to think that maybe that won't
be the case but I think this game sets
up pretty well 4 a.m. Mykel goes defense
is built in such a way that everybody's
got a responsibility he calls a triple
responsibility meaning that almost all
offenses with this RPO stuff going on
have basically ways to have basically
ways to you know
play option football if you do this I'm
going to do that right and so all of his
defenders have a responsibility it's not
just play the ball or play a gap it's
they've got responsibilities on players
Tunga bi-lo is not a run threat they
don't have Jalen Hertz as a backup so
they're not really using his legs so I
think they're going to be able to corral
some of these yards after catch which
have been such a monster weapon for the
tide and I don't think they have st. the
same pass rush right they don't have
some of the monsters that have been up
front in the past for Alabama's and some
young guys in that defensive front so I
think Ellen Monde is going to have a
little time to throw and that wasn't the
case when they play Clemson it wasn't
the case when they played Auburn and I
think for that reason I think a.m. is
going to stay in this game and if they
do that getting into the fourth quarter
then I think that a hundred
thousand-plus crowd can factor into this
thing Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst joining the Rich Eisen
showing to me I think kind of the game
of the weekend one in which you know we
get a chance to see Joe Burrell again a
quarterback of LSU on the national stage
going against the Florida team that you
know last week they found a way to win
they beat Auburn but when you look at
right now the way that LSU is playing
they seem like the biggest contender to
beat Alabama and obviously if they play
against Georgia as well but right now
the more and more I look at LSU they
just look like a complete football team
and am i right on that assessment Rick
well it's the old adage if you can't
beat them join them so they couldn't
beat Alabama playing the way they were
playing which was three yards in a cloud
of dust way you know Leonard fournette
was beating his head on the wall right
but at the so they went and got this guy
Joe Brady from the New Orleans Saints
and if you talk about a guy whose stock
has gone straight through the roof
it's Joe Brady because this offense
doesn't look anything close to what
we've seen in the old LSU team so if
someone came down from Mars having been
a college football fan they'd say we
landed on the wrong planet that that's
not a lies
you we've got to go someplace else they
just set a record for the most points
ever scored in the first four weeks of
an SCC season and boro has been
brilliant the question remains and I
think we're going to find out a little
bit more this weekend against Florida
how they'll do against a great pass rush
check that box for the Gators they are
definitely that and if they get Zuniga
back this week that'll even be better
against great corners check that box
with Marco Wilson and CJ Henderson those
guys are really good this is going to be
a fascinating game the question is what
kind of shape will for to be and
offensively given that magnitude and the
physicality of the game last week
against Auburn in this contest given the
fact that LSU didn't have that kind of a
monster game they kind of won one-sided
game against Utah State so I think that
you have to lean towards the Tigers
there at home but do not sleep on Dan
Mullen I think he's always got a trick
up his sleeve and I like this Kyle trask
if he's healthy I think he can play
salty enough quarterback to keep the
Gators in this thing all all four
quarters yeah you know one more game I
got to throw at you coach just because
we're joined now by Rick Neuheisel CBS
sports college football analyst but as I
look throughout the slate obviously
there's going to be some separation for
some teams at some point you got to
figure out who are gonna be the
contenders obviously in the SEC big ten
in the big 12 but right now I'm gonna
focus on the big 10 because we've seen
Ohio State their Idol this week they
don't play anyway but you mentioned Penn
State earlier you've mentioned some of
the other teams as well but where
they're Michigan at the end of the year
picks it up but how do you see right now
the the Big Ten kind of playing out well
I think Penn State's certainly a in a
position to show that they're gonna have
an opportunity to take on Ohio State and
and maybe be successful the other team
will be Wisconsin Wisconsin in five
games has three setups I don't care who
you're playing you shot people I'm
pretty good on that side of the ball and
they also have the best running back in
the country and Jonathan Taylor who's
having a monster see
so if Wisconsin can continue to play
they got a tough challenge this week
against a really good run defense in in
Michigan State but if Wisconsin holds
serve this weekend and plays Sparty and
beats him by a couple of touchdowns like
Ohio State beat them a week ago then
you're going to be sitting there going
wait a minute Wisconsin at the shoe here
in a couple of weeks is going to be one
of those games where we're going to be
sitting there going ok winters in it
it's going to be a really fun game to
watch but I can't say enough about
what's going on in Camp Randall given
that three shutouts and the offense is
clicking with this Jack cone at
quarterback and Jonathan Taylor doing me
all everything thing at running back but
you know what's fascinating is it's
fascinating and I'm transitioning
because here we are talking about all
these big games over the weekend karenge
we haven't talked Clemson in Florida
State those two teams used to be playing
both won national championships within
the last what six years it was 2013 when
Florida State won one Florida State's
falling that far off and we aren't
talking Notre Dame and SC how you got
always gets top billing and here's where
the Trojans are see you've got to fan
bases there at USC and at Florida State
that are sitting there going when are we
gonna get back in the conversation which
i think is also fascinating as we meet
as we reach the halfway pole in college
football yeah you kind of read my mind
that I was my last question for you just
looking at the USC Notre Dame game is
that we don't even talk about that one
anymore because Notre Dame it's probably
still in that era but as a top 10 team
in USC 90 of is of the unranked of teams
right now so that game has kind of lost
its luster and I still think that USC
has a chance to go out and upset Notre
Dame USC is playing hard for their coach
yes they are the story within the story
there is can clay Helton survives you've
got a new president there on the campus
at USC she's already taken Lynn swans
resignation so what is to become of the
head coach Lynn swans
longer there that but the team is
playing their tail off for him that was
on on display when they handed Utah out
their only loss on a Friday night in the
Coliseum they got beat two weeks ago
against Washington up in Seattle that's
a tough place to play I think this is
the all-or-nothing around right here for
the Trojans and I expect them to play
like it to circle the wagons and play
tooth and nail against the Fighting
Irish I think the Irish probably win the
game but I think it's another one of
those games it's going to go down to the
final drive hey Rick I look forward to
your analysis this weekend as I'm on my
flight back from Kalamazoo Michigan so I
get a chance to watch you on the flight
back as as you as you get a chance to
get some work in you and Brian Jones
there on college football today on CBS
thanks for the time Rick you bet I
deserve combat pay this weekend sitting
next to Brian Jones watching that Texas
Oklahoma game III seriously I have to
wear earplugs yeah they're shrapnel
shrapnel when you're sitting next to
that rascal it's always like that
absolutely enjoy the college football
weekend oh you too coach sounds good
that's Rick Neuheisel CBS sports college
football analyst for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app